c'est l'heure de vérité
c'est un des vérités pour sauver notre
système de retraite par répartition ou
ceux qui travaillent financent leur
retraite de ceux qui ont travaillé
les partenaires sociaux ont montré la
voix avec agir Carco ils nous ont
expliqué que 62 ans c'était un tenable
et qu'ils ont même demandé qu'il y ait
diminution de 10% des retraites pendant
3 ans
chacun connaît les problèmes de
démographie chacun connaît les problèmes
de petite retraite des carrières
arrachées des femmes alors le courage
c'est d'agir le courage c'est de dire la
vérité et la vérité
je vais vous la dire ce matin vos
mensonges c'est d'avoir tronqué le débat
démocratique avec les 20000 amendements
parce que Mélenchon le guide suprême
vous a interdit de le faire le courage
c'est de dire que ici il y a eu 175
heures de débat plus que jamais mais ça
vous l'aurez fuité le courage monsieur
Coquerel qui a disparu malheureusement
vous qui avez raison lorsque vous
activez l'article 40 sur les textes
financiers vous le refusez pour votre
tête et bien vous n'avez pas le droit de
vous arroser un tel pouvoir d'un
constitutionnalité le courage c'est de
dire aux Français qui nous regardent que
ce texte s'il était abrogé il n'y a pas
de chemin au Sénat il ne passera jamais
le courage c'est de dire que ce texte ne
franchira pas l'apport du Conseil
constitutionnel alors arrêtez de mentir
et de faux espoirs au peuple la vérité
c'est que le groupe yote malheureusement
n'est pas nombreux mais Charles de
Courson est là
Charles de Courson qui m'a formé dans
cette maison qui apprenait les 65 ans
pour la retraite à taux plein Charles de
Courson
qui avec moi en 2013 a signé des
amendements pour la retraite à 64 ans
2020 Charles de Courson qui m'a dit un
jour ne pas agir c'est bafouer la
démocratie et bien
Jean-Luc Mélenchon chercher Jean-Luc
Mélenchon chercher son hologramme
pendant la campagne présidentielle il a
un visage il a un nom c'est Charles de
Courson
et la vérité et la vérité c'est que vous
mentez aux Français parce qu'avec votre
texte je regarde la nupesse est-ce que
oui ou non vous rétablissez la retraite
à 60 ans non c'est la réforme du règne
morceau est-ce que oui ou non
verétaliser les régimes spéciaux non
vous mentez au peuple mensonge alors mes
chers collègues
mes chers collègues l'hypocrisie absolue
l'hypocrisie absolue c'est les 7
milliards que nous mettons sur la table
pour les femmes pour les carrières
hachées pour les aidants pour les
pompiers ça voulait garder
et puis et puis il y a la grande muette
ils sont pas là il y a ceux qui se drap
dans les draps de la vertu mais qui ont
dit dans cette réforme sur les retraites
ou pas grand chose Madame Le Pen disant
dans son document présidentiel on va
revaloriser le titre retrait on ne sait
pas de combien on sait pas pour qui
impeccable pas vu pas pris mais nous
nous avons vu et il y a un amendement
formidable dans lequel le RN nous
explique qu'il faut cotiser 42 ans
lorsqu'on a démarré à 24 ans pour avoir
une retraite à taux plein je vais pas
vous infliger une addition ça veut dire
66 ans une retraite à temps plein vous
êtes démasqué
alors
mes chers collègues
le chemin est simple vous avez le chemin
de la mélenchonie la mélancolie et le
chemin de la mélenchonie c'est celui qui
n'accepte pas le verdict de l'élection
présidentielle de Monsieur Mélenchon est
arrivé troisième
c'est le message de la mélenchonie qui
fait tout bloquer qui a déposé mon
pauvre salle de Courson pour qui j'ai
beaucoup d'affections il le sait 2000
amendements commission voilà la
mélanchenille et puis il y a le il y a
le rassemblement national la présidente
n'est pas là
qui porte désormais un nom le
renoncement national ne rien faire pour
que tout soit fait et bien mes chers
collègues vous aurez compris que le
blocage c'est vous l'action c'est nous
les mensonges c'est vous la vérité
difficile à dire c'est nous nous
opposerons à ce texte et les Français
nous regardent et auront vu vos
mensonges ce matin je vous remercie mon
cher collègue
[Applaudissements]